former white house press secretary ari
fleischer mara liasson national
political correspondent of national
public radio and jason riley wall street
journal columnist and senior fellow at
the manhattan institute we're just just
digesting this abc interview george
stephanopoulos with president biden we
heard a bit of that there we're going to
play another sound bite in just a second
but ari to see the president come out
today in the middle of what has been
really three four five days of chaos in
kabul and give that a speech about
booster shots and then walk out of the
room as a former white house press
secretary what were your thoughts
you know i always try to put myself in
the shoes of why is the president doing
what he's doing he must have a good
reason and when you hear the tone and
those snippets of his interview with
george stephanopoulos he sounds so
exasperated with the questions he's
getting he sent it that way at the july
news conference if you recall recently
why are you asking me questions it's a
three-day weekend i don't want to talk
about afghanistan you know joe biden
strikes me as one of these people has
been around so long has seen it all
heard all he knows it all and so when he
says to the military
you're out we're coming home that's it
he doesn't want to hear all the
complications the other problems that
will ensue as a result of it he just
says i've heard all your excuses before
just bring him home
and i think he's checked out
i think that's the only thing he was
interested in and that's why this has
backfired so much all right we're gonna
play the extended uh part of the first
uh clip of the interview we got from abc
and then there's another part we've just
brought in uh maura take a listen to the
the longer first part
you've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen afghans
fall
four days ago five days ago what did you
think when you first saw those pictures
well i thought was weird we have to gain
control of this we have to move this
more quickly
we have to move in a way in which we can
take control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow there's a
way to have gotten out without chaos
ensuing i don't know how that happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
now mara today the defense secretary
said we do not have the capability to go
out and collect americans outside of the
airport they have to get there yet the
state department sent out the embassy
alert
today that ended with the united states
government cannot ensure safe passage to
the hamad karzai international airport
and went on to say that they're asking
the taliban to ensure that safe passage
yeah i mean
the the the messages from the white
house are so confusing i mean basically
the message from biden today on abc is
it had to be this way there was no
alternative and he seems to suggest
since he said it was priced in that he
knew it was going to happen but then you
have general milley saying that there
was no intelligence that suggested that
the afghan government and military would
collapse in 11 days you also have joe
biden back on july 8th when he was asked
your own intelligence community has
assessed that the afghan government will
likely collapse he said that's not true
so was he blindsided was he not
blindsided it just
we can't get a kind of straight picture
of what happened
and to say that this was the only way
things could have unfolded i think is
just
not a good enough answer
well here's some more uh answers and
i'll let you assess whether they're good
enough or not another long clip from the
abc interview let's take a listen
and are you committed to making sure
that the troops stay until every
american who wants to be out is out
yes how about our afghan allies we have
about eighty thousand
people well that's not is that too high
that's too high the estimate we're
giving is somewhere between 50 and 65
000 folks total counting their families
does the commitment hold for them as
well
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31st but if we don't
the troops will expand we'll determine
at the time who's left
and
and if they're american force if there's
american citizens left we're going to
stay to get them all out
we we got there eventually jason but um
what would you take from that
i i bret i i think that the taliban is
lying to the u.s government about its
intentions and i think the u.s
government in terms of the biden
administration is lying to the american
people about its hands being tied
as mara was just referring to there's no
reason we should believe anything that
the taliban is telling us as part of the
trump administration agreement the
taliban was supposed to break ties with
al qaeda they have not done that
according to a u.n report as part of
that same agreement they were supposed
to enter peace negotiations with the
afghan government as we can all see they
are taking over this country by force
the bide administration has decided to
turn
afghanistan over to some of the worst
terrorists on the planet
and they're trying to present surrender
as courageous some act of courage and i
don't think the american people are
buying it
but there is there was a hunger ari to
get troops out but how we got them out
and what we did to get them out was the
key part there's some amazing video
today coming out of afghanistan of women
mothers
handing over their children over the
fence to try to get them into the
airport even though they know they can't
get there we didn't hear that and
there's some of that video right now we
didn't hear that empathy that uh emotion
at least not yet from president biden
and this is where he said that chaos was
inevitable and he was clear-eyed about
the chaos brad he wasn't clear-eyed he
was two-faced
when he held that july news conference
he was asked he said he had confidence
in the afghani military he said that
they were strong 300 000 best equipment
best trained why didn't he say at that
time no this will be chaotic he didn't
level with the american people he took
two totally different stands depending
on what was happening on the ground in
afghanistan and what's happening on the
ground of afghanistan is he blew it
instead of having the proper sequence of
withdrawal which should have been
civilians first equipment second troops
last he had troops come out first which
is why civilians are now endangered our
equipment has been captured and the
troops had to go back he blew it last
thing quickly mara what do you think the
long-term political impact of this
moment this week
is for this president
well i can say right now it doesn't look
good because he's presiding over a
debacle but over time i think it depends
on what happens in afghanistan does al
qaeda get another safe haven do they
launch attacks from there what kind of
images are we going to see about the
treatment of women and girls and
you know the american people sometimes
have a very sometimes have a very short
attention span
uh if afghanistan settles down maybe he
won't suffer great damage right now i
think there's no other way to look at
this than a bad thing politically for
biden right now hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else